bonsoir à tout ce nous sommes jeudi 26
mai merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
les titres de cette édition
la plateforme d'accueil pour demandeurs
d'asile du chesnay n'ouvrira pas la
préfecture l'annoncé cette semaine suite
à l'inquiétude d'une partie des
habitants en cause l emplacement du
cycle nous y reviendrons et cette
semaine a commencé la sixième édition de
la quinzaine des usagers vulnérables de
nombreuses actions régional de
prévention sont mises en place en ile de
france et dans les yvelines ceci afin de
sensibiliser les piétons les cyclistes
et les utilisateurs de deux roues
motorisés aux dangers qu'ils encourent
pour nous en parler ce soir notre invité
béatrice rigaud jurés coordinatrice
départementale de la sécurité routière
dans les yvelines et roland garros a
commencé le week-end dernier aujourd'hui
dans notre chronique sport nous vous
emmenons regarder du côté des coulisses
à la rencontre de sébastien lomé fini ce
n'est pas encore une star du classement
atp mais un jeune il une loi qui est
ramasseurs de balles cette année dans le
tournoi nous l'avons rencontré et pour
commencer cette information aujourd'hui
salariés étudiants et chômeurs étaient
appelés à se mobiliser contre le projet
de loi de travail dans les rues de paris
les premiers chiffres sont tombés entre
18 et cent mille personnes auraient
manifesté ces chiffres sont bien sûr au
nom définitif
dans les transports la grève sncf a été
moins suivie
ce jeudi qu'elle ne l'était hier le rer
b temps pas très affecté par le
mouvement social pas de perturbations
sur la ligne c trois trains sur quatre
circulaient sur la ligne l du transilien
et trois sur cinq sur la ligne e huchet
la direction de la sncf confirme par
ailleurs un retour progressif à la
normale quasi généralisée pour demain
vendredi 27 mai et en ce qui concerne la
pénurie d'essence l'état a eu recours à
des mesures exceptionnelles
hier pour éviter la pénurie comme des
fonctions dans les réserves stratégiques
de carburant et des interventions
musclées pour débloquer 11 dépôts
pétroliers paralysé par des manifestants
de nombreuses stations rationne le
carburant à présent les
usagers ne peuvent parfois acheter que
20 euros de gasoil ou d'essence la
situation devrait se compliquer le
mouvement de grèves les blocages des
raffineries 5 sur 8 sont bloqués hier
devrait se poursuivre cela jusqu'à
vendredi sien est toujours en lien avec
la mobilisation aujourd'hui un seul
quotidien étaient présents dans vos
kiosques que vous l'avez peut-être
remarqué
l'humanité est le seul journal à avoir
accepté de publier la tribune de
philippe martinez chef de file de la cgt
les autres quotidiens aurait donc refusé
la publication est donc ont été bloqués
en impression mais aussi en distribution
nous sommes allez vous demander ce que
vous en pensez
cette pratique va écouter faut un
blocage pour tout pour se faire
comprendre et se faire entendre là je
suis pas sûr que ce soit la bonne
solution parce que justement les gens
sont pas forcément au courant de tout ce
qui se passe donc bloquer certaines
choses oui mais pas peut-être pas les
informations malheureusement parfois on
est obligé d'en arriver là pour pouvoir
se faire entendre
donc il ya forcément des gens qui en
pâtissent mais si ça peut faire entendre
les choses à madame telle connerie
pourquoi pas après je suis pas sûr que
ça soit là la meilleure façon de
procéder pas légitime pour moi pas
légitime plus bas parce que je trouve
que c'est anormal de priver tout le
monde les journaux pour une tribune que
quelqu'un vous publiez je pense qu'il ya
d'autres moyens de se faire entendre
je trouve que enfin c'est l'accès à
l'information et que ça devrait pas être
politisée
je pense que la cgt se met vraiment tout
le monde à dos en ce moment et on
regardera un petit peu plus tard ce que
ça donne mais ils ont rien gagné à là
dedans et je vous disais en titre la
plateforme d'accueil pour demandeurs
d'asile du chesnay n'ouvrira pas c'est
une annonce de la préfecture et de la
mairie de la ville qui est tombé
vendredi dernier la semaine dernière les
habitants du chéné à fait exprimé leur
mécontentement devant le bâtiment situé
à proximité de l'école versailles s st
jean est un emplacement qui provoquait
la colère et l'inquiétude des parents
d'élèves et des riverains
plus de détails avec camille lambert
c'est dans ce bâtiment du chesnay que
les demandeurs d'asile devaient être
enregistrées en vue d'un accueil en
préfecture un projet désactiver vendredi
20 mai par le préfet les yvelines
en réponse aux inquiétudes des riverains
la plateforme d'accueil devait être
situé rue laurent gaudé à proximité
d'une école
ce qui a provoqué l'incompréhension des
parents d'élèves et de la mairie du
chéné même si nous sommes tout à fait
conscients qu'il est nécessaire de
pouvoir instruire le dossier des
migrants
ce lieu n'est pas du tout fait pour dans
une rue étroite du chesnay et contigu à
versailles puisque nous sommes en face
l'établissement de saint jean de béthune
qui a plus de 4000 enfants qui sont là
avec peu de trottoirs donc un lieu tout
à fait inadaptée philippe brillault
affirme n'avoir été au courant du projet
que deux semaines avant l'ouverture
prévue
plusieurs habitants manifester dans la
rue le 17 mai en face du bâtiment lors
d'une visite
même après son annulation le projet
divise cet afflux de migrants
incontrôlée n'est pas du tout une source
de sécurité pour la ville
parce que ils font rien de mal quand
même si gens là c'était mieux qu'on
trouvait l'auteur droite nicole d'autres
endroits chesnais qui serait faudrait
pas ce genre de problème il faut
comprendre l'inquiétude des parents le
lieu aurait dû ouvrir la semaine du 23
mai accueillir des demandeurs d'asile
soudanais tibétains et marocains une
soixantaine par semaine essentiellement
des hommes âgés de 30 à 40 ans
l'association qu al yah en charge de la
gestion de la plateforme ne jugeait
pourtant pas l'emplacement inadapté les
personnes viennent elles verront leur
situation nous enregistrons lors les
aidant à remplir leur formulaire
d'admission au séjour
prendre rendez vous elles repartent avec
leur rendez vous et ensuite elles
continuent leur parcours d'un service
qui n'étaient pas de nature à provoquer
du désordre
la préfecture des yvelines n'a pas
souhaité communiquer elle cherche
actuellement d'autres lieux plus
approprié pour accueillir la plateforme
de qu il ya philippe brillault s'est
engagé à aider les services de l'état
dans cette direction et l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
organise pour la première fois un
congrès sur l'histoire à des médias
pendant deux jours conférences et tables
rondes vont se succéder au théâtre et à
la bibliothèque de l'université
un événement qui est à l'initiative du
centre d'histoire culturelle des
sociétés contemporaines
il rassemble de nombreux spécialistes et
historiens autour du thème de penser les
médias et les détails avec william l
pendant deux jours ils vont confronter
leurs méthodologies et leur expertise
ces scientifiques spécialistes des
médias venus présenter leurs travaux sur
l'histoire des médias vont apporter un
autre regard sur le sujet nous sommes
aujourd'hui tous s'accordaient pour le
dire pétri nourri de culture médiatique
secteur médiatique elle vient de loin et
précisément c'est ce que nous étudions
va faire le point sur la recherche sur
nos méthodes sur nos problématiques sur
les perspectives d'avenir de la
recherche alors que cette recherche est
beaucoup développée depuis une vingtaine
d'années presse écrite radio télévision
ou internet tous les formats sont
développées des formats mais aussi des
questions sur la place du journaliste
celle du lectorat ou encore l' approche
du genre dans les médias l'arrivée
d'internet est une révolution qui a la
même dimension que celle de l'imprimerie
à la fin du xvème siècle d'immenses
conséquences
il est normal que du même coup on soit
désemparés l'histoire des médias peut
aider en rappelant ce que la longue
durée en réinjectant de la lenteur dans
la réflexion et dans les comportements
l'histoire des médias peut aider je
crois les citoyens à se comporter de
façon plus lucide et plus efficace de
vin devant internet qui est désormais
envahi nos vies
l'événement organisé en collaboration
avec cinq autres laboratoires de
recherche francilien devrait revoir le
jour d'ici deux ans jusqu'à demain soir
de nombreuses tables rondes seront
organisées de l'archéologie à l'histoire
du jeu vidéo
une manière de comprendre et anticiper
l'avenir des médias
en étudiant leur histoire et ce matin
jeudi 26 mai avait lieu au palais des
sports de ammour pas le premier
challenge robotique scolaire organisée
par la ville d'elancourt 400 élèves
saint quentinois de la maternelle au
lycée étaient présents chaque groupe
était invité à présenter son robot
devant un jury composé d'ingénieurs de
représentants de l'éducation nationale
et des différents partenaires camille
lambert et sephora nahman y étaient
présentes mind 'robots' et le nom du
robot construit par cinq élèves de la
première et sein du lycée
dumont-d'urville de maurepas il
participe au premier challenge robotique
scolaire organisée par la ville
d'elancourt une heure par semaine avec
leur professeur d'informatique pendante
pour moi ils ont construit leur robot et
on a pris et le codé et le programme et
ce projet nous a permis de travail
unique ifu apprendre à programmer
c'est une interface nouvelles on
connaissait pas avant de la plus grosse
difficulté c'est pour ce projet c'est de
faire tourner donc on a dû créer un
programme spécial pour le faire tourner
et l'appliquer la plus-value pédagogique
c'est que on fait plus courts chapitres
un contrôle le chapitre de contrôle ont
fait du projet donc soit le projet ont
réussi si on réussit pas comme dans la
vraie vie ça leur apprend à s'organiser
à travailler en équipe à prendre en
compte l'avis des autres plus de 400
élèves de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines était présent ce
matin pour l'occasion au palais des
sports de maurepas de la maternelle au
lycée
chaque groupe présenté son projet
pédagogique celui ci pouvait être
accompagnée d'un projet artistique pour
que les jeunes développent compétences
scientifiques et techniques de façon
ludique saint quentin et dans les huit
zones mondiales classées par le et
mighty dans l'innovation
actuellement aujourd'hui un robot on est
à 1 % de ses possibilités demain il sera
à 100% donc il s'agit que les enfants
comprennent ça élabore sans par
s'approprient cette nouvelle culture qui
fera marcher les usines demain donc
voilà on les forme tout de suite à à
être les meilleurs techniciens et des
ingénieurs 2 2 2 de cet avenir qui
arrive bien sûr sur le monde avec le
numérique un jury composé d'ingénieurs
de représentants de l'éducation
nationale et des différents partenaires
a récompensé les lauréats de chaque
catégorie de la maternelle au lycée
chaque vainqueur a pu repartir avec son
robot les lycéens ont même eu la chance
de remporter un mini drones et parlons
santé à présent il répare plus de 5000
mans par an c'est le centre d'urgences
de la main de l'hôpital a pris vite de
l'ouest parisien à trappes il fait
partie des premiers centres d'excellence
pour soigner la main en ile de france
frédéric lefebvre l'un des douze
candidats déclarés à la primaire de la
droite et du centre s'est rendu ce lundi
dans ce service le retour sur cette
visite avec fanny bourdon
un service d'urgence trois blocs
opératoires sept chirurgiens l'hôpital
privé de trappes s'est spécialisé dans
la main et se place premier en ile de
france en nombre d'urgences opéré de la
main et de l'avant bras en 2015 ils ont
réalisé plus de cinq mille interventions
on a un très grand bassin d'attraction
qui va loin jusqu à chartres dreux
rambouillet donc ça dépasse les yvelines
nous sommes un centre d expertise qui
est reconnu sur l'ensemble de la france
parce que nous sommes régulièrement
classé dans les dix à quinze premiers
centres de la main de france et nous
sommes en général le premier ou le
deuxième centre d'urgences de la main
pour l'île de france
en 2007 la fédération des services
urgences me décerne à l'hôpital de
trappes le label sos mains qui atteste
de l' expertise du centre frédéric
lefebvre en campagne pour les primaires
des républicains s'est rendu sur place
ce lundi pour rencontrer les équipes
je voulais d'abord me rends compte sur
place de l'efficacité de ce qui a été
mis en place notamment la coopération ce
qui est très rare entre le public et le
privé et le fait qu'on se soit placée du
côté du patient pour construire un
système une grande efficacité
la chirurgie de la main sos mains et
tout ce qui a été entrepris ici à
l'hôpital de trappes doit servir
d'exemple plus globalement pour réformer
le système
ce grand chirurgien a créé cette
structure en 2003 aucun service
spécialisé dans la main n'existait alors
dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui il fonctionne 7 jours sur 7
24 heures sur 24 est la sixième édition
de la quinzaine des usagers vulnérables
à commencer cette semaine campagne de
sensibilisation effectué par la
direction régionale et
interdépartementale de l'équipement et
de l'aménagement
à cette occasion de nombreuses
initiatives d action régional de
prévention sont mises en place en ile de
france et dans les yvelines afin de
sensibiliser les piétons des cyclistes
et les utilisateurs de deux roues
motorisés pour nous en parler ce soir
nous accueillons béatrice errigo jurés
bonsoir à vous remercie d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes coordinatrice
est départemental de la sécurité
routière auprès du préfet dans les
yvelines alors précisément dans les
yvelines le programme est vaste il ya
énormément d'initiatives pendant cette
quinzaine
oui tout à fait je peux peut-être vous
préciser les initiatives qui concerne
surtout les jeunes et donc cette année
nous menons une action vraiment très
importante en étroite relation avec
l'éducation nationale
nous visons
a travaillé dans plusieurs lycées des
yvelines et nous visons très précisément
les classes de seconde
alors pourquoi justement les classeurs
de seconde eh bien nous souhaitons
d'abord les jeunes de seconde sont les
plus réceptifs en cette période de
l'année
puisque les premières et les terminales
préparent leur bac
les seconds sont donc encore tout à fait
ouverts pour recevoir nos messages et
enfin depuis un an nous propageons la
bonne parole et nous essayons de
convaincre années scolaires de seconde
de s'initier au permis de conduire
puisque désormais dès l'âge de 15 ans
ils peuvent bénéficier de l'approché de
ce qu'on appelle la conduite accompagnée
dès l'âge de 15 ans alors il a aussi
d'autres événements fin vous travaillez
avec eux donc les lycées voûte réussi
après des entreprises biais
d'initiatives pour justement les
travailleurs qui utilisent leur voiture
dans le cadre de leur travail
oui tout à fait des entreprises comme
thales veolia lance des opérations à
l'égard de leurs salariés pour lutter
contre l'accidentalité des salariés lors
des déplacements professionnels ne sont
pas assez informés en général si mais il
faut toujours rappeler le respect de la
règle des salariés sont toujours en
retard quand est arrivé au travail ils
ont toujours très pressé lorsqu'ils se
déplacent dans le cadre des horaires de
travail et ils sont victimes d'accidents
de la route trop fréquent alors il ya un
événement phare dans cette quinzaine
s'espacent mardi donc à lui baissé de 50
ans est venu avec la diffusion d'un
documentaire justement à ceux de
prévention oui en fait il s'agit pas
vraiment d'un documentaire il s'agit
d'un véritable film qui a réalisé coline
serreau il ya déjà quelques quelques
années et ce film est une sorte de
documentaire par la mesure où il n'est
pas réalisé par coline serreau avec des
comédiens mais elle s'est déplacée dans
différents centres de sensibilisation à
la sécurité routière ce qu'on appelait
autrefois les centres de récupération de
points
et elle filme les français tels que nous
sommes et au fur et à mesure que se
déroule le film on voit l'évolution de
l'esprit des
des français qui avaient tendance à
mépriser les règles et qui grâce à
l'intervention des psychologues des
intervenants dans ces centres évolue et
se rendre compte à la fin de leur stage
que oui il doit absolument changer de
mentalité et de pratiques est ce que tu
as fait ce film sera diffusé au grand
public vers une possibilité de voir ce
film là déjà été diffusés au grand
public tout à fait mais la présence du
délégué interministériel à la sécurité
routière qui est rattachée au au
ministre de l'intérieur et sa présence
tout à fait exceptionnel dans les
yvelines ainsi que la présence du préfet
doivent donner une dimension nouvelle à
la diffusion de ce film qui en fait
n'est pas ouvert au grand public
c'est un film et qui réservait la
diffusion de ce film est réservé aux
professionnels de l'éducation routière
donc nous invitons les gérants d'auto
école les gérants des centres de
récupération de points et tous les
acteurs de la sécurité routière dans le
département
alors c'est la sixième édition vous avez
suivi voilà nombre de c2c édition de la
quinzaine
donc dès des usagers à vulnérable
est ce que c'est si le cd&v sont
victimes des autres usagers la route
donc les automobilistes ou bien est ce
qu'ils se mettent eux-mêmes en danger
seul we7 cette quinzaine a pour objectif
de sensibiliser l'ensemble des
l'ensemble des yvelinois
certes certains sont plus victimes que
d'autres des accidents de la route
mais nous sommes tous parfois sans nous
en rendre compte à l'origine d'accidents
de la route
nous en sommes victimes et nous en
sommes aussi à l'origine donc il s'agit
pendant cette quinzaine que chacun
d'entre nous se réapproprie les règles
de partage de la route et les règles du
code de la route il ya des peut-être des
éléments de base à rappeler mais que
l'on oublie souvent tant que conducteur
ce week-end sont les éléments vassard à
rapper qu'il faut pas oublier que
peut-être certains ont tendance à
ignorer ne pas boire d'alcool avant de
conduire ne pas consommer de drogue qui
d'ailleurs ceci est totalement interdite
il ne passe en consommer du tout
respecté strictement la vitesse enfin
respecté ce qu'on appelle le partage de
la route acceptée que la personne qui
est devant nous conduisent peut-être pas
aussi bien qu'on le souhaiterait
c'est ce qu'on appelle le partage de la
route respectez la les piétons respecter
les cyclistes respectent et des deux
roues motorisés et motards et
inversement que les motards aussi
respecte chacun des usagers de la route
justement est-ce que parfois les piétons
commettre des erreurs mais elles ne sont
pas forcément à même de savoir et se met
en danger seul c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel
ce ne sont pas les piétons qui qui sont
les principaux responsables de
l'insécurité routière
alors il ya il ya aussi des revirements
concernant le code de la route on l'a vu
dans l'actualité va le code a changé
finalement il a été remanié est ce que
selon vous l'état daté la conduite
actuelle alors les revirements ne
concerne pas le code de la route en
lui-même le code c'est un ensemble de
règles que chacun nous devons respecter
l'examen du cas de la voilà ce qui vient
de jeu de ce qui est un petit peu
nouveau c'est les
la série de photographies que nous
proposons aux candidats tout à fait
c'est quelque chose de renouveler sans
être véritablement nouveau cd crise ou
de renouveler et s'est adapté à la
conduite actuelle selon vous peut être
qu'il faut approfondir justement ce code
de la route qu'il met peut-être pour
protéger plus les usagers
non je pense qu'il est parfaitement
adapté si chacun d'entre nous respecte
ses règles et s'est parfaitement adapté
il faudrait peut-être je sais pas
remettre un petit peu les idées au clair
et avenante qui ont déjà leur permis
depuis un certain nombre d'années mais
ce serait envisageable si les
initiatives dans ce sens oui mais c'est
ce que font les entreprises lorsqu'elles
réunissent leurs salariés pendant cette
quinzaine de la sécurité routière
le fait que vous organisiez par exemple
est aujourd'hui cette rencontre avec
avec moi pour parler de la sécurité
routière permet à chacun de se se dit ah
oui tiens il faut bien que je respecte
les règles que j'ai apprise
elles n'ont pas véritablement changé
depuis que chacun d'entre nous a passé
son permis de conduire simplement nous
devons les respecter et ne pas les
négliger
sinon fait un rapide bilan de la
sécurité routière dans les yvelines ce
sera ma dernière question il y a de
moins en moins d'accidentés comment cela
l'expliquer ce que les gens sont plus
font plus attention avec les différentes
campagnes qui m oui je crois que nous
pouvons être optimistes
effectivement depuis une dizaine
d'années les tendances sont à la baisse
néanmoins une vie tu es c'est une vie de
trop nous avons le devoir de lutter
jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait zéro tué sur les
routes des yvelines et c'est ce à quoi
nous nous employons collectivement merci
beaucoup à béatrice et rigolo juré
d'être venu sur notre plateau d'avoir
répondu à notre à nos questions alors si
vous souhaitez plus d'informations
justement sur cette quinzième de la
sécurité routière dédié au visage est
fragile n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur
un site internet du
yveline point buffo affaire qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran merci à
vous recherchez bouclier et les chiffres
du chômage ont été dévoilés hier par
pôle emploi le chômage poursuit sa
baisse en avril en ile de france le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi de
catégorie a n'ayant pas du tout
travaillé dans le mois
diminue ainsi de 0 5% par rapport à mars
soit 3540 chômeurs de moins sur trois
mois la baisse est de 1 4% pourtant dans
les yvelines on note une légère hausse
de 0,4 point mais attention ces données
doivent comme d'habitude à être
commentée avec prudence quelles raisons
étaient perturbés spécialement par le
comportement des personnes émargeant au
service public de l'emploi il y aurait
eu de nombreux défaut d'actualisation et
nous recevons à présent sur ce plateau
notre journaliste sportif michael et
demi d'euros pour la traditionnelle
chronique sport du joli bonsoir à vous à
michael safrane ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce moment et bien merci qu'est le
thème de votre chronique d'aujourd'hui
sont alors sortez votre panama et vos
lunettes de soleil floral aujourd'hui je
vous emmène du côté de la porte
d'auteuil l'un des tournois de tennis
les plus prestigieux au monde a débuté à
dimanche dernier je vous parle bien sûr
de roland garros floral les chiffres de
ces internationaux de france on vous
donnait le vertige 128 joueurs et
joueuses quatre cent mille spectateurs
1300 journalistes
près de 4500 raquette 45 tonnes de terre
battue 66000 petite balle jaune sur les
courts 250 ramasseurs de balles ont été
sélectionnés pour la compétition
retrouve notamment une quinzaine divine
mois parmi eux sébastien l'homélie ni à
13 ans licencié au tennis club mini
montain depuis cinq ans il a été retenu
pour la première fois par les
organisateurs en les gouttes
en fait je voulais être ramasseur de
balle pour voir des grands joueurs voir
des beaux matches
et si on lui casse une occasion unique
je suis quand même fier parce que
on est que à peu près 250 sur 3000 donc
c'est pas beaucoup c'est moins d'un
dixième
et surtout on peut voir beaucoup de
joueurs c'est génial sébastien ça a été
un beau rameau surtout la journée voilà
on a bien évolué et surtout la journée
ramasseurs plutôt efficace en terre donc
il ya bien la chance quel est le
programme type de ramasseurs de balles
pendant une journée à roland garros et
ce qu'il fait un match plus après 48 non
pas du tout florane vous trompez les
ramasseurs de balles âgés de 12 à 16 ans
arrivent généralement très tôt le matin
entre 7 heures et 8 heures et repartent
le soir vers 21h et réalise au total
quatre à cinq heures de ramassage par
jour avec des rotations toutes les 30
minutes pour pouvoir tenir la cadence
florane il faut donc une bonne condition
physique et surtout maîtriser
parfaitement les gestes techniques du
ramasseur de balles
en fait faut réfléchir avant la fin d'un
point ce qu'il faut faire après le point
donc
et quand il demande la balle faut lui
donner simplement on a des balles dans
la main et on les fait rouler
vers les autres ramasseurs les bons
roulés s'est déroulée qui font pas de
rebond et qui sont rapides et wat
ramasseurs de balles faut être avoir une
bonne motricité est rapide du vif sur le
terrain avoir une bonne compréhension du
jeu et être efficace sur les roulés et
on sait qu'ils sont la technique de base
de rendre sur le ballon si on veut voir
les fameux roulé de sébastien rouler les
rouler c'est ça c'est comme ça que ça
s'appelle on peut les voir sur quels
cours bas pour le moment sébastien
officiers notamment sur les courts
numéros 16 et 17 depuis le tournoi de
qualification et a notamment vu
l'espagnol de 32 1 32 ans guillermo
garcia lopez mais également les
française pauline parmentier et mathilde
johansson
mais le jeune il monte un prêteur et
pourrait être surclassé dans les
prochains jours et notamment aller sur
le court central philippe chatrier où le
suzanne lenglen
comme nous l'expliquent son évaluateur
elles sont notées toute la journée par
les évaluateurs qu'en fin de journée
avec les superviseurs du staff on voit
là on fait un petit récap sûr surtout
les notes et après on les met sur
certains terrains pour le lendemain
l'objectif de ce jeune unis montrent un
dé transmettre des ballots numéro un
mondial novak djokovic rafael nadal pour
les quarts de finale où les demies où le
souhaite évidemment de réussir son pari
vous allez le voir dans les prochains
jours florham alors j'ai pas encore la
changez pas eu des billets pour la
quinzaine comme vous eu michael vous
êtes un peu plus chanceux mais bon si
vous avez un billet en 3 voilà n'hésitez
pas à annonay vous avez un panama et des
lunettes de soleil toujours sur moi on
verra alors du coup pour vous
aujourd'hui on vous retrouve attention
je retiens ce que vous dit on retrouve
dans quelques minutes pour d'autres talk
et si on parlait sport quel sera le
programme alors avec nos chroniqueurs
nous parlerons notamment de la montée en
nationale 2 du chesnay versailles du
boxeur à laurent courtois marvin petit
qui combattra sur le ring du cirque
d'hiver souvent on dit à 27 mai mais
également aux turcs or d'apnée dandy
cabreira on en avait parlé la semaine
dernière c'est vrai un programme
toujours captivant merci beaucoup
michael maintenant nous passons au
quatrième volet de notre série sur le
cnc après avoir vu l'étendue d'un
patrimoine cinématographique
l'inventaire et la valorisation des
collections
nous vous proposons de découvrir
aujourd'hui le service de restauration
des films lorsque la pellicule d'un film
arrive au cnc de bois d'arcy
elle n'est pas toujours en bon état 7
pellicule va donc passer dans un
laboratoire c'est guillaume ansquer et
william
à qui vous montre cette suite là on a
les yeux pers tour eiffel lorsqu une
pellicule arrive au laboratoire du cncc
par cette machine qu'elle passe en
premier dans cette essuyage les plus
petits défauts du film comme les poêles
ou les poussières sont enlevés
à la sortie la pellicule et propre est
prête à passer à la prochaine étape la
tireuse les certains films sont trop
abîmés pour aller directement en machine
et doivent passer par une restauration
manuel beaucoup plus poussé avec des
produits que vous voyez en dessous
assouplir le film c'est que en gros
tapis se décompose en règle générale qui
se solidifie il devient très très dur et
cassant ce qui nous empêche totalement
les passées en machine en fait
fort heureusement que des mecs comme
celui là sur ce film les perforations
sont abîmés ou arracher une casse qui
est souvent due à un passage trop
récurrent en machine de projection alain
va devoir réaliser une colonne pour
rajouter les perforations manquantes
la plupart des les entraînements machine
se font avec des petites griffes des
petits picots qui vont attraper des
perforations et entraîné le film donc
s'il ya plus de faire formation
entraînement n'est pas possible lorsque
les perforations sont restaurés le film
est en état pour passer à la tireuse
c'est ici que les films seront
sauvegardés en dupliquant le film sur un
nouveau support
la majeure partie des pellicules qui
passe sur cette machine sont les films
les plus anciens sur support en nitrates
ici transposée sur support de sécurité
car la sauvegarde reste l'objectif
premier
le but en argentique c'est vraiment près
normal de préserver le maximum mais
négatif d'origine on pas que pour pas
qu'ils s'abîment plus à force de
manipulations le but de base et d'un
film ici c'est vraiment d'obtenir un
nouvel élément par exemple si un film on
n'a qu'un seul négatif du négatif c'est
pas en soi
un élément de travail c'est vraiment le
piquet en faire un positif pour ensuite
faire un contrat type k1 négatif qu'il a
est voué à être travaillés les avant de
pouvoir travailler dessus le négatif
doit passer par l'étape du développement
sur cet appareil
la pellicule va rentrer d'un côté et
passé par plusieurs bains
dans la pellicule palais
à la sortie de la machine l'image
apparaît enfin sur le film un film qui
va devenir le principal support de
travail pour le cnc permettant à
l'original d'être préserver et conserver
encore plus longtemps afin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivis
demain je vous retrouve votre journal de
fin de semaine avec l'essentiel de la q
je vous souhaite donc une excellente
soirée et à demain